I think most of us dread Mondays because
culturally we've learned to dread
Mondays we live for the weekend our
music is you know celebrates Fridays
better than Monday our movie celebrate
Fridays better than Monday and and maybe
our parents did too
I think there was a generation that
didn't have the same freedoms you and I
have 30 years ago 40 years ago I
couldn't have this conversation where I
could say to the camera to everybody
watching hey you have a chance to plug
into a community that will help you you
didn't how would you even find those
people in 1960 how is your mom or your
dad going to find a community of other
people other photographers other artists
other bankers other anything's easily
they couldn't so I think we have access
to people and tools and experiences that
no other generation had access to and so
in addition to that being a huge
opportunity it's a huge responsibility
we have a chance to break that mode of a
job is just a job Monday is horrible and
Friday is great what if we got to
reinvent that what have we got to rescue
Mondays and that doesn't mean be fake
I'm not saying tomorrow turn a frown
upside down no I'm much more practical
than that you're going to have some
difficult days some Tuesday's that
aren't fun there's no such thing as a
perfect job that's one of the things
that cripples people they think I have
to find the perfect job where I only do
things I want to do and that doesn't
exist but what if you could say okay can
I use more of me at my next job can I
use more of me on a Monday than I got to
you a week ago can you use more of the
things I'm good at
can I start to look forward to going to
work can I start to look forward to a
Wednesday and not just live in this
culture that only celebrates Friday I
don't want us to have a life where we
feel like Tim Robbins at the end of
Shawshank Redemption as we drive away
from work on Friday this sense of relief
finally I got out of that because here's
the thing that's really bad math and
here's what I mean by that somebody say
to you we'll give you two weeks of
vacation in exchange we want you to give
us 50 weeks this year 54 to is terrible
math trading 50 weeks of misery for two
weeks of vacation is bad math trading
five days you don't like for two days
you do like again is bad math training
years of your life I mean that's the
thing that's why I write about career
you're going to do this thing for 40
years 40 to 60 hours a week let's invest
in it let's make it as good as it can be
let's make it as awesome as it can be
because it matters we're talking about
four decades of your life certainly we
should lean into that